let's talk about the mutations
the virus that causes covid19 keeps
changing
there are a bunch of new versions and
they're more contagious
countries around the world seem to be
scrambling trying to keep
up and stay ahead of these variants
one's hit the uk hard
and it's spreading around the world
there are others
in south africa brazil nigeria too
but should we be worried some people
think well
you know if this virus is changing and
it's more transmissible there's nothing
we can do that's just not true
so how big a problem are these mutations
will the vaccines still work
and the big question many of us want
answered when will this all
end
2020 gave us the kind of pandemic no one
alive today
had ever seen before a year later 2021
is starting out with the same pandemic
only now it's on steroids one reason is
there are new versions of the virus
but scientists say that's not exactly a
surprise viruses mutate all the time
it's just what they do viruses usually
spread within species
animal to animal person to person but
sometimes they mutate
and do things like jump the species
barriers say
that's what happened with swine flu mers
and this one
sars kovi ii a virus exists
to replicate evolve and spread and it
does that by hijacking a cell's
reproductive system to make copies of
itself
so it can spread to other cells and onto
other hosts
and as it gets copied over and over
again sometimes there are mistakes
think of them as typos those changes are
called
mutations many of these changes have
very little
to no impact on the virus itself and
in fact many of these changes are a dead
end for the virus
but every now and then a mutation comes
along that makes the virus
better at what it does the key is
opportunity
for example healthy people have immune
systems that fight the virus for maybe a
couple of weeks
but people who are already really sick
with weak immune systems
could play host to the virus for much
longer it gives the virus more time to
mutate
that's what they think happened with
these new strains but there's a
hypothesis
that they originated from an individual
who was immunocompromised and the virus
was replicating inside their body for
many weeks many months so the virus was
changing inside that individual
and then that person transmitted to
someone else and that's why we saw so
many mutations all at once
in the uk a single variant of the virus
known as b117 has
23 mutations it showed up in september
2020
and according to the world health
organization they think it could be
about
70 percent more contagious than the
original wuhan strain
researchers at imperial college london
say that even with a lockdown
similar to that in england in november
the number of cases would still triple
let's look at it this way using what's
called the reproduction number
this coronavirus was known to spread
from one person to two to three other
people on average
the r number was between 2.5 and 3.5
that's without things like social
distancing and lockdowns to control the
spread
with those measures the r number came
down the virus was infecting maybe just
one other person
or fewer which is enough to stall the
spread but then this new uk
strain showed up and pushed the r number
back up to as high as 1.7
and this strain has traveled but there
are other strains too
another new variant of coronavirus has
emerged in nigeria
south africa has been hit by a new
variant
it's important to point out though that
while these new strains might be easier
to catch
the who says the data coming out of the
uk so far
suggests no change in disease severity
or in the number of people dying
okay here's the next question will the
vaccines still work
on those mutated viruses while the who
says
right now the answer is yes because the
part of the virus that these vaccines
um are targeting is relatively stable so
we're
for the moment this this looks to be
manageable
still it's not impossible that more
genetic changes down the line
mean we need to tweak the vaccines it's
why scientists around the world have
been keeping an eye on how this virus is
changing
they've done more than 300 000 gene
sequences of the virus since the
pandemic began
so there is a strategy to track and deal
with mutations but the who says that if
anything
the mutations are a wake-up call and
that it's up to us
individuals and governments to do what
we can to stop the virus from spreading
and mutating in the first place look at
what happened at the end of the year
people traveled they spent time with
friends and families
all against health advice fight the
bullet and sacrifice that social
gathering
fatigue rises
it is the season to be jolly but there's
also the season
to be jolly careful the out shopping
the mixing of families will increase
transmission regardless of if it's a
variant or not
and what does all of this mean for the
end of the pandemic
well right now the plan is still to
vaccinate as many people as possible
to build immunity as fast as possible
even though vaccines can only do so much
i think many people thought that
vaccines would be rolled out
and that we would be able to end this
within a couple of months but we're
really looking at
this entire year of rollout and into
2022
scientists knew the coronavirus was
going to evolve from the get-go
but the health advice to sit tight and
stay safe that hasn't
changed and for those of us who want a
hard and fast answer on when this will
all be over
well the who says anybody who gives you
a date
they'd only be guessing
as with every story about the current
virus the experts are still trying to
work out the science and the journalists
well we're trying to make sense of it
too and stay as accurate as possible
so make sure to visit trusted sources to
get health advice and
information stay safe and i'll see you
next week